- [Instructor] Many of you
all are probably familiar
with the term evolution,
and some of you all,
I'm guessing, are also familiar
with the term natural selection,
although it isn't used
quite as much as evolution.
And what we're going to do in this video
is see how these are
connected, but we're also
going to address some
potential misconceptions
that folks have about evolution.
So when a lot of people
think of evolution,
they think of a diagram or an image
that looks something like this.
They can see what they
would consider to be
a more primitive ancestor evolving into
a more sophisticated, a more
modern type of organism.
And this is going from
some type of primitive ape,
all the way to human beings.
Now there's some aspects of this diagram
that give the right idea, that
evolution is the phenomenon
that organisms over time can evolve,
can change in their
traits, that can actually
become different species.
Now the one thing about
this diagram that might
be misleading is calling
this character primitive
and somehow imagining
that this one in the front
is better or more advanced.
Evolution doesn't necessarily go
from good to bad or primitive to advanced.
It's really just continual change based on
what is most suitable for the environment
in which the organisms are in.
And this can take millions of years.
For example, the common
ancestor of human beings
and other apes like
chimpanzees or gorillas
can be five, 10 million-plus
years in the past,
but it can also happen
right before our eyes.
For example, every year
we have a new flu virus
because the flu virus
is constantly evolving
through mutation.
We have the Coronavirus and we're having
new variants of that, it seems like,
almost every few months.
That is evolution happening
right before our eyes.
But the key question is, how
does this actually happen?
Does the DNA know to
change into something else?
Well, clearly not. The
DNA is not sentient.
It is not somehow constructing itself.
And that's where natural
selection comes into the picture.
So let's imagine a
population, and I'm gonna
think about a very abstract population
of these little circle-shaped things.
And an important characteristic
for evolution to happen
is that you need variation
in the population.
And we talk about variation,
we're talking about
different expressed
traits, and you might ask,
"Where does that variation
actually come from?"
Well, it's going to come from mutation.
I talked about variation
when we think about viruses,
the flu virus or the Coronavirus,
and it can also come
from sexual reproduction,
and we go into a lot of
detail in other videos
how sexual reproduction mixes and matches
all of the potential alleles
that are in a population
so that different
members of the population
are getting different
combinations of those alleles,
and so that contributes to variation.
And that variation by itself
does not lead to evolution.
You need variation and selection pressure.
And this is really where the term
"natural selection" is coming from.
What do I mean by selection pressure?
Well, in this little example here,
if these circles and
triangle-looking things
could just keep
reproducing, they could find
as many resources as they need,
there's no shortage of food,
there's no shortage of
environments in which they can live
and reproduce, they had no predators,
well, you're not gonna
have selection pressure.
And so all of these variations
might have an equal chance
of living their life and then reproducing.
But now let's introduce
some selection pressure
and imagine what might happen.
Let's say we introduce
the selection pressure
of a predator that has a much
easier time seeing white.
Well, then what's going to happen?
Well over time, generation to generation,
the white circles and
triangles here are going to be
much more likely to be
eaten by that predator
before they can reproduce
and pass on the allele
or the alleles that might
result in this white trait,
and so next generations
or future generations
are going to have fewer and
fewer of these white shapes,
so the next generation
might look a lot like this.
A lot more of the purple we're seeing
and a lot more of the blue.
Now on the other hand,
you could have a scenario
where instead of a
predator that sees white
and can't see the other colors showing up,
where there's a shortage of food.
So that's another form
of selection pressure.
Let's say a more triangular shape
is useful for finding food.
for food.
Well, then what's going to happen?
Well, generation by
generation, these shapes
that are more triangular are going to have
a better chance of
surviving and reproducing.
And so maybe in the
first generation you have
maybe something like that
does reasonably well,
something like that could do very well.
Something like that would do well.
Something like this could do well,
but we're gonna see, we might see
a few of the circles still.
We might see a few of these characters,
but we'll see fewer have them.
And we're gonna see more
of these characters right over here.
And now you can imagine if this
environmental pressure continues,
then over generation and generation,
you keep selecting for more triangular,
if you could go forward
many hundreds or thousands
or hundreds of thousands
or millions of years,
you might see some
subset of this population
that lives in this environment.
They might have a very triangular shape.
They might not even look
anything like their ancestors.
Now, does this mean that
this shape right over here
is somehow more advanced
or better than what
their ancestors saw, or maybe
there's a cousin species
that was where the predators see white
and the triangular shape
really doesn't help you,
and so they have a cousin
species that looks like this.
There's no way of saying that this species
is more advanced or
better than this species,
but what we can say is, it is
more fit for its environment.
And this species is more
fit in its environment.
So I will leave you there,
and it's important to realize
this isn't some magical process.
It's all due to variation
caused by mutation
and sexual reproduction,
selection pressure,
and then that change happens over time.
And this isn't just something that happens
over millions or tens
of millions of years.
It happens before our eyes every day.
When we talk about the
different flu strain
or a different coronavirus strain
or drug-resistant bacteria,
it's very relevant to
our day-to-day lives.